in the last video we'd had a little bit
of a review of classical economics and
then we talked about how Keynesian
thinking was a departure especially and
why it might have made sense in the
context of the Great Depression where
the economy was operating well below its
potential what I want to do in the end
it may be true anytime that the economy
is operating well below its potential
but what I want to talk about in this
video is how Keynesian thinking can
sometimes be dangerous and one thing I
do want to emphasize over the course of
this video is key Keynesian policies are
often associated with people on the left
with with policies on the left but
Democrats in the United States but the
Republicans also are for the most part
especially mainstream Republicans
especially the last several
administration's they have practiced
what are what can only be described as
Keynesian policies when the economy
started to recede
they tried to stimulate it by shifting
aggregate demand to the right somehow
and we'll talk about that they tried to
do it in a slightly different way
through tax cuts instead of government
increases the spending increases but it
was Keynesian and its underlying
thinking now just as a bit of a kind of
back up I'm going to talk a little bit
more about that cycle that we talked
about in the last video so if you had
person a person B person C and person D
or maybe they're firms and B supplies a
a supplies D D supplies C and C supplies
B and for the sake of simplicity we said
that they're also applying two units of
their good and service to each other and
let's just say that C has a bad dream
feels pessimistic ate something bad and
all of a sudden that isn't feeling good
about the future and wants to buy less
just out of caution maybe wants to hoard
a little bit of cash and things this in
case she needs it and so he buys a
little bit less from D so he buys a
little bit less than D but D says gee my
business is bad now I can't afford as
many goods and services buys less from
AAA does the same thing from B and then
bees business is bad so buys less from
less stuff from C goods and services
from C and now C feels like they're
psychic but even though we see that it
was actually a self-fulfilling prophecy
that sees pessimism actually led to that
reality actually occurring and in a
worse case that actually could get worse
and worse he could see wow I was
pessimistic and I was right
my business actually did get bad maybe
even got worse maybe even it got worse
than she had expected and then c-could
then say well I'm gonna buy even less
maybe I'm only gonna buy a half from D
now and then D says maybe I'm only going
to buy a half from E and that cycle
could go down and down and down until
each of them are just buying exactly
just just what they need to get by even
though they all could be producing more
the economy could be producing more it
could be wealthier and they all could be
way better off and so this might this is
at least in my mind a pretty good
description of what happens in
depressions especially the Great
Depression and so there might be a
rationale to say hey look why don't we
why doesn't the government come here at
some point in this economy
and stimulate demand so why doesn't the
government come here so let's say B is
already buying one from C the government
comes and says hey I'll buy another one
I'll buy another one from C and then C
says hey gee things are good again I can
buy two from I can buy two from D D
could buy two from a and then a can buy
two from B and then B can buy two from C
and so things have kind of gotten back
to their potential state the economy is
revving now in an ideal state the
government would say hey my work is done
now I can now take a step back I could
take a step back and I don't want to
overheat the economy I don't want to
push aggregate demand too far to the
right and cause inflation and so they
will they will take a step back now the
danger here is that this is not so easy
for governments to do this was some type
of stimulus some type of government
spending although maybe it was a tax in
maybe was a tax a decrease and maybe B
could have increased their demand but
either way once you do a policy like
this and let's say it was government
spending it's very hard to unwind this
government spending might have been for
project that some people like it might
have employed many many people those
people are voters they're not just going
to sit there while you cancel this
government project and so there's a risk
that maybe there is a justification for
Keynesian policy but when it's time to
undo that Keynesian policy to undo that
stimulus it's very hard to do it it's
kind of a sticky policy and so what you
might have is when times are bad you do
is Keynesian stimulus stimuli but then
when times are good
not willing to undo it and that
Keynesian stimuli involves more and more
deficit spending or more and more
government spending then the government
size is just going to grow relative the
economy or the deficit is just going to
go around to the economy and you're
never going to unwind it because the
unwinding is unpopular and I want to be
clear that this is true of both the left
and the right in the stereotypical sense
the left might say hey let's do a Keynes
Ian's stimulus by spending more so the
government spends more and let's hold
our revenue constant our tax revenue
let's hold it constant and so obviously
the government would have to borrow more
money to fund this but or sometimes they
might even increase taxes if they
actually want it to be more purist about
it but this is the variety that you you
see and this would be a true stimulus
this is it using the fiscal lever to put
more demand in the economy but on the
right you often see the other side you
see taxes being lowered essentially
saying instead of the government
spending it why don't we let people
decide where to spend it and they might
spend it in a more efficient way and but
it's going to be a stimulus because
spending is held constant and then you
have the double where where you do both
sides of it where you lower the taxes
you lower the inbound revenue and you
increase spending so and this is true
this has been done by both Republican
and Democratic administrations lowering
taxes but then going and starting a
hugely expensive war and obviously this
will increase deficits and there might
even be a justification for doing any of
these Keynesian justification if the
economy truly is operating well below
its potential the tough thing is is it
might be justified you actually don't
know exactly where that potential is and
you might not be able to unwind this
once you get to your potential then you
might overheat the economy might lead to
inflation and that will that actually
might undermine the productivity of the
actual economy the other negative of a
Keynesian mindset is what happens over
the long run in the short run this might
make a lot of sense let's let's prime
the pump let's get the cycle to happen
in the right way again but in the long
run it's essentially just trying to get
people to consume and consume more
you'll often hear when the economy slows
down a little bit you'll hear the
president you'll hear politicians say
hey we're just trying to get people to
spend more through some combination of
these Keynesian policies we're gonna
lower taxes we're going to increase
spending but they never say you
ever hear them say hey we want people to
save more so that we can invest more so
that in the classical sense so in the
classical sense we can increase our
total productive capacity now the US has
kind of gotten a free pass on this
because the US has been doing
essentially the deficit spending it's
been able to do the Keynesian stimuli
and and and that's why the US consumer
keeps spending more and more saving less
and less the government is doing the
same thing but the US has also been
getting investment because it's the
foreigners who have been saving and then
plowing that money and they've been
essentially investing in the u.s. so
that the US could increase its
productive capacity but that is a risk
for a country if it's not blessed with
that kind of free pass that the US has
gotten for the last several decades is
that when you have some resources so in
a given year you have some resources
let's say it's your time you could
either hunt you could either hunt and
eat rabbits or you could use those or
you could spend your time to invent new
rabbit trapping devices so this is kind
of the hunting and eating the rabbits
and this is spending some time to go and
figure out ways to be more productive at
hunting rabbits building some bow and
arrows or something like this you always
have a trade-off between consumption and
investment and Keynesian policies
they're all about hey let's get
consumption as high as possible and that
might be a good idea in the short run
especially if we are operating well
below our potential well below our full
capacity utilization but it could be a
risk in the long run if you don't get
the free pass because you might have
under investment and in the classical
sense you're never able to move your
potential to the right